for more I'm joined in the studio by dr.
you'll expect she's a professor of
psychology at the Free University in
Berlin dr. Spector welcome to tomorrow
today hello why are twin studies so
valuable to personality research
well twin studies can inform us about
how differences between person between
individuals can be explained and when
studies found that about half of the
differences between individuals are due
to genetic differences and that about
the same amount of differences are due
to environmental inferences that means
what people experience in their life
let's talk about those genetic
differences for a minute now researchers
in Bonn recently said that they found a
gene or a gene variant that was linked
to absent-mindedness how strong is the
evidence that certain genes are linked
to certain personality traits well we're
just at the beginning and finding genes
that translate into your personality
characteristic but it seems to be the
case that it's rarely the case that we
have single specific genes that cause a
specific personality trait but it's
rather an interplay of different genes
that enhance the probability that a
specific personality trait will EQ in a
person so it's really the case that we
have one gene and this gene causes one
personality trait your own research
focuses on personality development
what's the most surprising thing you
found well in this study where we use
data of about 15,000 individuals from
all of adulthood we found that people in
young adulthood are pretty do change
pretty much in their personality and
this is also true for people in old age
again and this is something that was
really surprising for us because it is
common knowledge about personality
development list that there are lots of
changes in young age but it are
comparable comparatively strong changes
in old age again was something pretty
new and we were very surprised to see
that is surprising what are the ways
that people change in old age well we
see that individuals turned on average
to get more Constantius as they age they
get more agreeable with age especially
in old age and there are less open to
experiences when getting older hmm now
let's say I'm an introvert and I want to
become a bit more extroverted how would
I go about that is that even possible
well it seems to be the case that it's
possible so it's possible to change
personality but not in one huge stat but
we need to change personality in in
small steps so this means it is possible
to change the personality but it takes
time and patience so if a person would
like to be an extrovert this person
could aim at changing the personality in
specific situations and then this would
get automatic in behavior of this person
and this could really change personality
as a whole it's interesting I was doing
some research before the show and I
found your blog you arrived which is
fantastic and you've got a little
section where you talk about the impact
of scientific research on relationships
and what's the most important thing that
personality psychology tells us about
our love life oh well there are lots of
findings from scientific research that
can inform our daily life but one of the
findings for example is that that if you
were looking for a partner it seems that
we don't have an idea about what kind of
partner would fit to us so if we do for
example online dating and we have the
idea that there is an agency or we
ourselves can identify the person that
fits your own personality this is kind
of an yeah the findings show that it's
not that easy to find a partner but that
it's a lot of chance having its hand in
this how how we get in love with a
person we don't know yet all right
that's some interesting news for online
daters there dr. speck thank you so much
for joining us here on tomorrow today
thank you